[Music]
the cover of the latest news week
features picture of President Obama with
the caption the first gay president yeah
yeah when he when he heard this Obama
said I missed the good old days when
they just called me a Muslim remember
when I was even born here people are
wondering who Mitt Romney's gonna pick
to be his running mate
I know I am yeah thanks pal yeah a
Republican official says that Mitt
Romney should pick quote an incredibly
boring white guy as his running mate
yeah when he heard Joe Biden said thanks
I've already got a gig the Facebook
founder and CEO Mark Zuckerberg turned
28 this week 28 years old yeah he he got
a watch from his girlfriend a sweater
from his parents and from the rest of us
all of our credit card numbers huh why
are you applauding that he's got
everything seen us all naked
well me anyway one by his house a an
Idaho man says he was bitten by a
rattlesnake at Walmart yeah the man grew
concerned when he saw something at
Walmart that was fast-moving and skinny
[Music]
dalia lama in the news the Dalai Lama is
saying he said something kind of
fascinating he said that China trained a
woman to assassinate him by putting
poison in her hair yeah luckily the
Dalai Lama had just recently stopped
eating hair
[Applause]
good enough good enough for a Wednesday
glad I don't try that tomorrow night
it's ping I had a fall before the show
I'm a little rattled
hey it's being reported that Snooki is
considering filming her childbirth yeah
well of course the hard part will be
getting the camera into the tanning bed
when there's a pause like that it's
patronizing he seems to like when we do
this yeah it makes red-haired clown
happy hey get this gang a janitor shut
up a janitor has graduated from Columbia
University with honors as a classics
major yeah with his new degree in
classics he's now qualified to become a
janitor
a new book is coming out about Helen
Keller secret love life that's true
Helen Keller's secret love life yeah
the book is called why do you keep
asking me to hold this hot dog
[Applause]
like you I was horrified
by that title it's a terrible title but
it is serious scholarship
thanks again friend sure